spring in cam Jordan he is the defensive
end for my New Orleans Saints who were
going to the Super Bowl and going to win
it next game will be at the Panthers
coming up on Monday night cam good
morning how are you I'm great
overly blessed on this one too for
Tuesday morning appreciate you having me
on where are you right now right in the
parking lot no it's a cool off day but
we are here to get it in the best car in
the Saints parking lot belongs to
Cameron Jordan I don't know you know I
feel like my 2011 top that's right for
my entire career I don't see me leaving
anytime soon
what you know I'm biased clearly well
that's a sensitive car that you have
there but who's got the extravagant one
who knows Tesla it's always nice you
know Mike T might have a great what I
think a K has a beautiful Jeep you know
my dog mark has a big truck that all men
dream oh it's got the big wheels on it
and you need a stepladder to get into it
no no doubt yeah no doubt ladder cuz you
know tallest of the bunch but I think a
dope monster what Sean Payton drive like
a Honda Accord or something that's
phenomenal question you don't know what
coach doesn't in there a parking spot
there that says don't even think about
parking here this is Sean Payton's no no
everybody's everybody's treating equally
I plus you figure you know we share a
parking lot with the pelicans and you
know yeah I have no idea that's that's a
different set of guaranteed money right
how about Anthony Davis Anthony Davis
blocking field goals I mean so you saw
[Laughter]
did you watch the game last night of
course
you know you have to watch Seattle you
know Seattle versus the Vikes yeah um
NFC to see my family you know they know
two NFC teams you know pops to play for
the Vikings for 13 years
well there's a vested interest in that
when you talk about you know Eric
Kendricks and Mike Kendricks my kids for
performer Cal Cal bear taking the field
you know gotta kind of love the
brotherly love situation what do you
remember about your dad playing for the
Vikings not much I was like four when he
retired but you know I probably got
every kids you know fantasy dreams are
just running around on the field tackle
you know dummies and drink some Gatorade
maybe watch some film with the man but
it's not like you're retaining a lot of
those those phenomenal merry memories I
wish I could have who runs the locker
room postgame that'd be you know a Shawn
Drew situation you guys have fun in
there you guys have fun in there yeah we
turn we turn it up one time for
everything that you know we've been was
once they put a speaker after the game
you know controls of music and it's
definitely deep inside teddy bridgewater
looked like he's kind of leading the
band in their daddy looked like you had
a little bit of fun Teddy Teddy yeah
yeah I mean Teddy Craig Robinson Chris
banjo you got you got everybody you know
dabbling into the fun Mark Ingram 8k I'm
definitely in the mix I need that you
know that concert after - after a great
win at the good hearts my bottle battle
I mean it's almost Hal I asked that lost
to the Cowboys how do you explain that I
don't I move on beyond a talk about hey
what are you Bill Belichick here Cameron
I'm a 24-hour I'm not even talking about
the last one we had at this point was
focused on Carolina did you see okay you
sent Cam Newton a bottle of wine last
year I plead the fifth
okay so you that means yes so you sent
him a bottle of wine after the Saints
knock the pan
out of the plans why did you send him
reportedly send him a bottle one
allegedly might have been a allegedly it
might have been a Jordan Cabernet that
was sent in great year was like a 2011
joelkat moon in 2013 if I was to send a
bottle of Cabernet that's been at of the
Jordan variety um do you know I just
feel like after after three hard-fought
battles the inner division opponent it's
not like it was the right thing to do a
great farewell gift but did he how did
he take it
I mean I don't know you know I feel like
I felt like he's a quarterback so he was
just too top tier he's a great guy he
just didn't even open the alleged the so
sad sent box of lime you know I didn't
hear anything about it I don't think
anybody did so like allegedly the but
you know about a wine was it
but would you okay you play on Monday
night would you say that right
can't or would you say to cam would how
was the how was the wine I mean I'd like
to check in it just to see you know so
same box was ever received bottle of
wine was drank it wasn't like it's a low
caliber wine that wasn't like a five but
Chuck no Jordan is a great great cab I
think it's a great gesture and 2011 was
probably a great year we're talking to a
Cameron Jordan by the way your do you
know where you rank on the Saints
all-time sack list I just I know for a
fact I just passed up you know my former
mentor Will Smith so that's somewhere
top five its Ricky Jackson with a
hundred and fifteen Wayne Martin has
eighty two and a half
hats willing seventy six and a half and
then Cameron Jordan seventy one and a
half okay but if I'm looking at a Hall
of Fame numbers like if you get to a
hundred sacks is that Hall of Fame
numbers yeah
yeah I think somewhere around eighty
five saxes how to say Paula fate I was
right if you just look at every
everybody who's been inducted in terms
of defense evangelize lady five sex
you're in conversation hundred sacks
puts you and that you know almost in
that first ballot situation okay am I'm
in my mind you know what she hit that
hundred sack threshold right the moment
gone don't think that this year that's
Hall of Fame that's golden jacket worthy
you know yeah that's that's exciting
number four defensive end
sure of career was if you were gonna
rewrite the quarterback protection rule
from a defensive perspective what would
be fair to both sides I mean I probably
just be just as biased as the league is
down protective coating Beckett
unprotected okay
you know for for everything it is you
know I at some point as long as the
quarterback is in the pocket I feel like
he sees fair game as long as you're not
going below the knees and in direct hit
if you get pushed into it you can pushed
into it I believe in that rule
I'm gonna blindside head you know these
trying to somehow hit a quarterback and
rotate out and you know all this extra
stuff that they would that the the focus
is on protecting the quarterback that
has to be sometime soon because at some
point this is a game of men and a
quarterback knows that you know this is
this is what he signs up for you know
sign it for like hey if you have a free
shot on me you can't take it if he hit
me you have to roll off you if you you
know if you hit me you can't hit me too
hard I don't I don't understand these
rules in a game where you know
everybody's running the fastest
everybody worked out their whole entire
lives to be the best that they can be to
be the ultimate competitors now is that
we've got this soft edge being placed on
us
and I don't understand it fully ever
felt sorry for a quarterback you hit all
the time
something really yeah I mean they
recorded back I hate them
yeah you don't feel that tomorrow I
don't know I don't know if that's a true
least I feel sorry for you but it's a
sorry you had to be in the way because
I'm sorry that was you
ever hit Brees in practice accidentally
no eyes in fact I've seen somebody tap
Brees and I got upset don't jeopardize
who's the quarterback on your hit list
that you haven't gotten you got you know
71 and a half sacks
aside from Drew my biggest one was like
maybe if I see him in a Pro Bowl I could
probably get one off when I hit him hard
I just want to pillow you know like hey
I appreciate you enjoying this book I
feel like Tom Brady would be the next
one he's eluded me the last you know
I've faced him I think twice now and
I've had him and he's chucked the ball
so I feel like I got a feel the deal
eventually he's not very fast camera not
at all but the man has an excellent
release he's six five he sees everything
six six and I'm talking about I've had
some clear shots out of least of all
it's highly irritating do you talk to
these quarterbacks on a personal level
you know I don't know if I want to know
quarterback personally that means I have
a vested interest of actually liking him
but on the you know in the game in the
moment oh I'm talking I'm talking at all
times if anything you know when a game
is intense enough you're going to have
those those wonderful exchanges and I
have those changes often with
quarterbacks
it's Cam Newton bigger than you yes to
40-ish 250s right he's a big guy he's
not my weight yet yeah but he's a big
man he took to the table quarterback you
know face bigger you know in terms of
like heavier most likely Ben
Roethlisberger him and Andrew Luck are
probably comparable right in terms of
size yeah and then you got drew who you
know it's like when he probably gets
carted when he comes into stadiums
they're like you're not the quarterback
I mean Drew and you know that's the
gunslinger you know everybody knows you
know the drew is a he'll never get
caught you'll never get carted his faces
is one of the top five most recognizable
in the league this Saints will be in the
Super Bowl
if win the Super Bowl is played
oh you're going I like to say that is
the goal of our team and so until until
we are derailed that privilege we feel
that we have everything in ours in our
sights lined up and that's our mission
well congrats so far and don't screw it
up I have you guys winning the Superbowl
I'm not one of those guys who jumped on
the bandwagon midway through the season
I I jumped on in August I so I have a
window seat in first class love it we
appreciate all the support and at this
point you know our season has been about
proving them right and we take every
game with this chip on our shoulder that
you know the world is against us and
we're here to fight this uphill battle
cam thanks for your time we appreciate
it good luck against the Carolina
Panthers on Monday night much appreciate
it that's cam Jordan he's the Saints
defensive end yeah his dad was a good
tight end I think six times five times
six time Pro Bowler with the Vikings for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]